the great white is the Sultan of the sea
typically it spends its days hunting
swimming and jumping
but as of 2010 just off the coast of
Australia
this apex predator
starts acting strangely
my right leg just looked like minced
meat
64. terrifying attacks
transform Australia's western coast into
its deadliest I'm just thinking what can
I do to stop this
what's called sharks to go on a killing
spree
shift in the species worldwide it's
imperative that we find out why these
attacks have occurred people are scared
to go back in the water
[Music]
Elise frankham grew up in the coastal
state of Western Australia and was never
far from the sea
the ocean has quite a very very large
part of my life
well I feel a connection
I feel at home
[Music]
in 2010 she leads snorkeling excursions
for tourists
I was just living the dream
[Music]
known for its rugged natural beauty
state of Western Australia is the site
of more than twelve thousand miles of
stunning Shoreline
year round swimmers and Surfers flock
here in droves
but they're not the only ones enjoying
these Waters
different species of sharks call
Australia home from the sleek and
slender blue shark known for its Indigo
Hue to the wildly patterned Wobegon
renowned as a master of stealth and the
polka dotted whale shark famous as the
largest fish in the sea these species
are all considered harmless to humans
but the world's most dangerous sharks
swim here too
nineteen-year-old Elise
is working at her job as a dive guide
so I was about three quarters of a mile
offshore
and we'd just gotten all the tourists in
the water as well
a familiar animal comes to play
it was a local dolphin
it's fun with her many times over the
years
and she had just had a calf
excited tourists gather around
but Elise notices something is off
the Dolphins they were being a little
bit erratic and they were darting off
and coming back
calf
in reality they may have actually been
warning me
[Music]
and then that's where it happens
an enormous shark has released by the
legs
my brain just went into fight mode
I tried to punch it
and I tried to push it away for me
but the shots grip
is too strong
I was in complete shock
seeing the struggle one of the other
snorkelers Dives to her Aid he wrapped
his arms around the shark
and just essentially wrestled it off of
me
definitely saved my life
Elise is pulled from the water
but her leg is ripped to shreds
that's when I realized the extent of
injuries
my right leg just looked like minced
meat
Elise is airlifted to the hospital
where doctors attempt to save her
mangled leg
it was a six hour surgery
they stopped counting out of 200
stitches
but in the end
the operation
is a success
and Elise maintains the ability to walk
swim in the water
but I've learned more of a respect
towards sharks
the true power and the greatness of them
Elise was attacked off the coast of
Western Australia just south of the
capital city of Perth
and while sharks have always been
present along this massive Shoreline
starting in 2010 they become a problem
more than 60 attacks in just 10 years
triple the number of incidents from the
preceding decade it's an unprecedented
uptick
[Applause]
shark attacks in Western Australia
previously were rare
now they're almost regular events
not only that
Spike includes a horrifying 11
fatalities earning this tourist haven a
terrifying designation as Australia's
deadliest Coast
the amount of vicious attacks there's no
question it becomes Talk of the Town
people are scared to go back in the
water
with residents demanding action
authorities put prevention measures in
place including aerial surveillance and
Beach enclosures but the attacks just
keep coming
so investigators take up the case in a
bid to stop the Bloodshed and keep it
from recurring elsewhere the more we can
research into what's happening then the
more human fatalities and human trauma
we're going to be able to prevent
so what's causing the sharks of Western
Australia to suddenly go on a rampage
shark expert Johann Gustafson believes
that a crucial first step in solving
this mystery is to identify the culprit
so he turns to a piece of evidence from
the attack on Elise
so here we have a fragment of tooth that
was largely thin the victim
Gustafson thinks this tooth must belong
to one of three species which are
responsible for the majority of the
attacks worldwide the first is the tiger
shark
so here we have a tiger shark Jewel and
we see on one side of the jaw the blades
are pointing to the left we're on the
opposite side of the jaw they're
pointing in the opposite direction
this allows Tigers to rip their prey
from both sides of their teeth
as they shake their heads back and forth
[Music]
a second likely culprit is the bull
shark
so with our bull shark that we have here
completely different shape of two
quite pointed serration is quite sharp
the bull shark's powerful pointed teeth
enable it to slice through its victim in
one quick lethal motion
but Gustafson believes the shape of the
tooth from elise's wound indicates a
different Predator with this tooth
fragments it's perfectly triangular and
it's quite serrated on both sides
without doubt I can conclude this came
from a white shark
great whites are the largest predatory
fish on the planet they use their
powerful tails to propel them through
the water at upwards of 25 miles per
hour
often striking their prey from Below
but this identification isn't limited to
elise's attacker
of the more than 60 attacks where the
species is known the majority of
culprits are white sharks
so what's causing great whites here to
act so strangely
and could it be indicative of a
behavioral shift happening across the
globe
perhaps the answer relates to a booming
industry that's centered around this
iconic species one that occurs in
several locations
All Began Down Under
cage diving
shark expert Dr Dan Huber explains
the way cage shopping operations work is
that boats use Chum to try and attract
sharks to the area
people then get into cages which are
submerged in the water to get much much
closer to very dangerous sharks than
they would otherwise be able to
driving has been a fixture of Australian
tourism for decades
but around 2010 something changed in
2010 when the spike in shark attacks
began the number of days that chumming
occurred on the water had doubled
compared to the previous year
so how might this uptick lead sharks to
go after people
at the aquarium of Western Australia
Marine educator Jess McLaughlin
investigates
she thinks there's a key parallel
between cage diving and a process that
occurs within this shark exhibit
we have 15 sharks in this tank here we
have seven different species of sharks
and every day McLaughlin's team feeds
these sharks in a particular way all the
shots get fed by buckets of the food's
kept in the bucket while this container
may seem insignificant it's anything but
the charts of Ashley learned that this
means feeding time this process is
called conditioning
it occurs when sharks recognize that a
particular stimulus can lead to a meal
in the wild this queue can be auditory
like the sound of a boat motor or visual
like the presence of a diving cage
in fact this conditioning can be so
effective that it kicks in any time the
stimulus is present even when the food
is not
to demonstrate McLaughlin prepares to
dive into the Shark's Tank with an empty
bucket I'll go to the feeding spots as
normal after the shots will come down
expecting to be fed
[Music]
McLaughlin descends into the tank
and before long
sharks approach in search of a meal
I really recognize that bucket with
feeding time which is a pure example of
conditioning and shows that it can be
done
this may be key to explaining the role
of cage diving in Australia's deadly
Spike
Because by chumming the water tour
operators are potentially conditioning
sharks to make a dangerous association
with the very hand that feeds them
there's definitely a possibility that
sharks have Associated people with food
because of cage shiving in Australia
[Music]
so if cage diving can teach sharks to
equate people with food could this
adrenaline-inducing activity be to blame
for the attacks in Western Australia
and maybe even other incidents around
the globe
Australia may seem synonymous with shark
attacks but historically they've been
few and far between
that is until 2010 when they hit one
state hard and fast
more than 60 incidents and 11 deaths in
just under a decade leave residents of
Western Australia got it I'm standing
here talking to you and you know some
others aren't
theory for the surge
diving has conditioned sharks to
associate humans with food
a shark expert Dr Dan Huber thinks
there's an issue with this Theory while
cage diving is very popular in Southern
Australia
it's actually been outlawed in Western
in fact the practice was banned by the
state in 2012.
as a direct result of its potential
to negatively alter shark behavior
so there's got to be more to the story
news diving clearly isn't the reason for
the spike in attacks
but one thing this Theory does show is
that the actions of great whites are
heavily motivated by the presence of
food
so perhaps a different prey item could
be linked to the problem here
local videographer Blair Radford thinks
he spots a possible culprit
[Music]
often Witnesses a striking phenomenon
one which occurs on a tremendous scale
on the coast here and we have what's
called
Australian salmon run
the Australian Salmon Run refers to the
annual migration of these large Oceanic
fish
every fall they head Westward along the
coast to spawn and they do so by the
thousands we see bait balls the size of
two to three hundred foot coming along
the coast and the salmon come really
really close to shore
that's where all the fishermen coming to
Target them
but something else is targeting the
salmon as well
sharks
the hungry Predators can often be seen
following these mobile buffets
sometimes in large numbers
and one of the ways they trap these fish
is truly incredible
to explain Johann Gustafson uses a
roughly two foot long dogfish shark
specimen visible on the Predator is a
finely tuned sensory organ
one so powerful it allows a shark to
literally feel its prey so here you can
see a really good example of the lateral
losses
the lateral line is a series of
fluid-filled canals running the length
of a shark's body starting from a
shark's head these cells are lined with
tiny hairs which are stimulated by
vibrations in the water and then
transmit signals to the brain
this allows sharks to detect the
movements of their prey from over 300
feet away sorry for sure is not able to
see that prey it'll literally rely on
that lateral line system to find it
in this way sharks can easily home in on
the location of a single fish
but their supersense is even more
effective when the prey source is
sizable so if there's a large paper or a
school of fish such as the salmon runs
they'll be able to feel a landslide of
pressure differences and this acts as a
strong enticement for sharks
as a result experts warn beachgoers both
here and around the world to steer clear
of schooling salmon or else they may run
into
a hungry shark
so could this massive salmon snack be
the cause of Australia's Spike
while experts have indicated that the
salmon could indeed be attracting hungry
sharks
it's also clear that salmon have lived
and migrated along the Australian coast
for years
long before the recent spike in attacks
so the salmon run is not responsible for
the taxider being occurring in Western
Australia
the reason for the surge remains a
mystery but another frightening
encounter holds a clue
Matt palella has loved the sea since
childhood
growing up in Western Australia were
always Outdoors fishing
surfing just enjoying the toy space
in 2014 Matt spends much of his free
time spearfishing alongside his good
friend Jay Muscat
Jay was very boy she was very cheeky we
had died together easily over 100 times
the boys are well aware that they're not
alone in the water
we always knew that sharks were going to
be a risk
but you never think it's going to happen
until it does happen
just four days after Christmas Matt and
Jay head out to a protected Cove
that they believe is safe
Jay I don't have that same place the day
before and seeing a lot of good fish
[Music]
so we're excited
definitely didn't have any worries
we've been in the water for about an
hour and a half
and then we decided to turn around and
start swimming back
but before they head in Matt takes one
last dive
as our kids forward
the shark hit me
it's also obviously in shock but
and it heads for another Target
Matt's friend
Jay
[Music]
a massive white shark Ram's teenager
Matt palella
[Music]
then turns toward his friend Jay
and I can say Joe's sort of struggling
on the surface
so fast pace I was just trying to figure
out
what's going on but before Matt can find
the shark returns
to him
I'm just thinking what can I do to stop
this
I've got a lot of speed out of my hand
but I decided to pull the trigger
the spear hits the shark in the mouth
and the animal immediately swims away
Matt scrambles back to shore I
definitely think shooting the shot side
mall off if I hadn't done that I
probably wouldn't be here today
but 17 year old Jay isn't as lucky
when Rescuers pull him from the water
it's clear
it's too late
the shop we did straight through his
family artery
I'm a nurse that now some dad at the
beach
[Music]
I was just gobsmacked
me and Jay we becoming really close
that's like brothers
[Music]
G Muscat is one of 11 victims killed
along Australia's deadliest Coast since
2010.
almost triple the number of fatalities
of the previous decade
and locals fear it's not over yet
when attack happens it's gut-wrenching
and no one can give you a guarantee we
could have a shark attack at any time
but perhaps a clue to this sudden surge
can be found in a detail from Jay's
attack when will Darwin used to say
bronze Wireless we should quite a common
shot
but we'd never seen a walk
that is until the day of their fateful
dive
sightings such as this have led some
locals to believe that the population of
white sharks here has exploded
some politicians also seem to believe
this Theory
in a response to a decline in white
shark numbers the Australian government
passed a law in 1999 to protect the
species and it is now illegal to kill
them
so is it possible this effort worked too
well and led to a population boom which
now endangers people
at the University of Queensland Dr Jenny
ovenden investigates
he's working on a long-term project to
track population numbers of great whites
and she's doing so using Advanced
scientific techniques can we take the
DNA from a white shot of Jewel and we
compare it to the DNA from another
individual and then we do that with a
hundred individuals
in order to obtain the DNA ovenden's
team has collected shark jaws from
contemporary specimens to ones dating
back decades we think that this shark
lived about 30 years ago
then they extract the genetic material
so we'll be drilling out some dried
material from law which contains the DNA
from this individual finally ovenden
analyzes the DNA
paying close attention to the gender of
each shark this allows her team to
estimate the number of sexually mature
females in the water both past and
present and based on the number of
breeding adults we can make inferences
about the total population size
ovenden's research is still ongoing but
although she doesn't yet know the number
of breeding females in the water
she thinks there's something else about
the mating process that's key to
understanding the attacks white sharks
have a similar reproductive biology to
humans they don't actually have very
many offspring per shark and the Sharks
grow quite slowly in fact great whites
aren't sexually mature until around age
15 and they only give birth to around
seven pups every couple of years
that means the 11 years that transpired
between the start of the Protection Law
and the start of the spike wouldn't be
long enough for the population to really
explode given the slow breeding cycle so
it doesn't really make sense that the
populations could have increased in such
a huge amount in a fairly short time
perhaps the answer to this bizarre
Oceanic occurrence is related to a
different Marine phenomenon
one with enormous swirling power that's
only recently been discovered
and it doesn't just happen in Australia
[Music]
the white sharks of Western Australia
are acting strangely
starting in 2010 they attacked more than
60 beachgoers in less than a decade
leading some to question whether the
behavior of this apex predator has
changed not just here but everywhere I
think everyone is absolutely Keen to
find out why attacks go up because it
has such a an impact on everyone who
uses the ocean
perhaps the shark's bizarre behavior
odd phenomenon witnessed at the very
same time
[Music]
in 2017
scientists pouring over satellite images
of the Australian coast
observe something they've never seen
before
a rare rotating mass of water called a
double Eddy
and Eddie is a swirling aquatic
formation much like a Whirlpool it
caused by powerful ocean currents which
move across the sea for miles
but sometimes two of these spinning
maelstroms can combine
Marine ecologist Johann Gustafson
demonstrates
so right here we've got a tank of water
and what we're going to try and do is
simulate a double Eddy
first he uses a plate to create
turbulence in the water
forming two separate Eddies
there we go to illuminate the swirls
Gustafson adds red dye to the tank
each Eddie spins in an opposite
direction
but before long the two collide
and link up
the tube will actually connect together
in sort of like a U-shaped walk of
Wormhole to make that double Eddy
the result is a force that's much larger
and faster than its single Counterpoint
a single Eddy can measure more than 60
miles wide and travel around one mile
per day whereas a double Eddie spans
upwards of 150 miles across
and can move 10 miles per day so they
have a much more significant effect to
our ecosystems compared to what a single
ladies do
because as these huge vortices churn
through the water it's believed they
essentially scoop up the tiny Marine
creatures that cross their path and that
makes the double Eddy a mobile Meal
Ticket the Eddies themselves they
contain Plankton zooplankton fish larvae
so you'll get other fish coming within
those areas for those food sources
this in turn May attract more dangerous
predators it is very conceivable that
sharks will actually follow those Eddies
so are great whites pursuing these
swirling smorgasbords into Shore where
people are
Gustafson thinks the answer comes down
to the frequency of these formations the
double Eddies are relatively rare event
while they have been recorded in
Australia more than anywhere else it's
believed they've only occurred a handful
of times since the early 1990s and they
last for just six months at most
so double Eddies are simply not present
enough to account for the attacks
the reason for the spike remains unknown
but a clue from a recent incident
provides a new lead
[Music]
I've lived in pre-surfing my my whole
life
I would surf every day if I could
in 2018
Nathan Birch is well aware of the area's
short problem
in fact his favorite Beach was recently
the site of two attacks on the very same
day
but the 21 year old still regularly
rides the waves there anyway
the thoughts of sharks is on top of
everyone's mind
[Music]
but when the wives are good it's just
natural to want to go surfing
in the early evening
Nathan his brother and some friends
enter the water
[Music]
the beach was a lot quieter than usual
but we all paddled out to have a bit of
fun
we were surfing for about an hour and a
half
and we're all sort of thinking about
heading in
so I was sitting on my board
waiting for that last wave
[Music]
and it all started from there
a white shark Rams Nathan on his board
everyone went into Panic friends
screaming
feels terrifying
the shark circles below Nathan
but the surfer acts fast
but I knew what I had to do I just
wanted to literally get to the beach as
quickly as I could
Nathan and the others make a desperate
break for the shore
crying at that moment that uh
everything's gonna be okay
[Music]
because it'd be really the end of
someone's life within seconds
[Music]
but everyone makes back unharmed
we're just shocked
it was scary scary event
to come out of it unscathed is kind of a
miracle
Ethan Birch
more than 60
have been attacked off Western Australia
since 2010.
but the sight of this attack holds a
valuable clue one that may not only
solve the mystery but also act as a
warning for vacationers
worldwide
Western Australia is under siege from
sharks
more than 60 attacks mostly by great
whites in just under a decade
the shocking victim count includes 11
fatalities making this the country's
deadliest Coast I definitely think
people are scared to go back in the
morning everybody wants to know what's
causing the spark of attacks but nobody
knows
however a detail from the recent attack
on Nathan Birch May hold a sizable clue
on the day of the attack within three
miles of where we were there was well
carcasses
are a common sight in the waters off of
Australia
over 30 species swim here from the
iconic humpback with its distinctive
knobby head
to the massive blue whale the largest
animal to ever exist on Earth
each year many of these Majestic mammals
migrate south along the coast of Western
Australia in search of food
but some don't survive the journey
and their remains can be found littering
this Shoreline
not just the sight of Nathan's attack
local Blair Radford heads to the site of
one such beached giant we're gonna get
our first glimpse of this wild caucus
just up ahead here now
it's a pretty big one
according to Blair deceased whales like
this humpback are an increasingly common
sight we've seen the whales washing up
more and more regularly in bigger
numbers than we're used to
earlier this year we had a number of
shark attacks and a Spate of other
incidents and it was a time of year when
we don't normally see a lot of great
whites along the coast here but during
that period of time we had well over 100
whales washer Shore
so
looks of whales
areas sharks
Dr Blake Chapman is a biologist and
shark expert
to investigate
she takes to the water
we're just heading offshore from Perth
this is quite a popular whale migration
route
she says that the connection between
whales and sharks
all begins with the Predator's most
iconic asset
sense of smell
sharks have been referred to as swimming
noses because they have an extremely
strong sense of smell
sharks use their extraordinary olfactory
abilities to find a mate or a meal
and this sense is so fine-tuned that
sharks can even tell which direction a
smell is coming from they can locate
sources of food just by comparing the
smells between the two sides of their
nostrils and then just really hone in on
it
in the case of Western Australia
the smell they may be homing in on is a
whale
sharks have been known to scavenge upon
dead whales in the water because the
mammals are rich in blubber but even
when a whale is decomposing on the beach
can still attract a shark's attention
as a large whale slowly decomposes its
carcass releases chemicals into the
water these secretions then leach into
the sand and eventually wash into the
ocean
creating an odor trail that can extend
for Miles the essential fuser going back
out into the water will be picked up on
by the sharks
for this reason experts advise
beachgoers worldwide to avoid swimming
in areas near a beached whale
or else they run the risk of an attack
farewell carcasses on the beach we know
that there are motivated sharks coming
in
so our pungent dead whales luring sharks
into Shore and increasing the likelihood
of encounters with humans
seems to hold water there's always that
chance that this is going to result in a
fight on a human
but when data from the spike is analyzed
it becomes clear that not every attack
site was in close proximity to a carcass
so it's just not enough to give the
whole picture to What's Happening Here
something else is going on
in search of a new lead shark expert
Johann Gustafson returns to the data set
and eventually a striking pattern
emerges
one that links the incidents to two
particular times of year the majority of
the attacks have occurred in winter and
spring
so why are these Seasons particularly
dangerous
the answer could affect Coastal
residents everywhere
great whites are wreaking havoc in
Western Australia
more than 60 attacks including 11
fatalities in just under a decade
have some fearing that the actions of
this species are taking on a chilling
new pattern
but investigators May finally be on the
verge of unraveling this bloody mystery
[Music]
shark researcher Johann Gustafson has
identified a crucial piece of
information about the spike
the majority of the attacks took place
during two seasons
winter and spring
in Australia winter and spring span the
months of June through November
during this time air temperatures are
still warm enough to attract beachgoers
but water temperatures have dropped and
Gustafson thinks this shift in the sea
is the reason that these two seasons are
so dangerous winter and spring is when
the water is cooler
those sharks are found throughout the
world's oceans in climates ranging from
the tropics to the Arctic cooler water
temperatures are especially attractive
to one species of shark
the same species responsible for the
majority of the attacks on people in
Western Australia and around the world
great whites
watch dogs are more commonly found in
cooler borders because they have an
adaptation that allows them to maintain
a warmer body temperature compared to
the surrounding Waters this process is
called thermal regulation it enables
white sharks to elevate their body
temperatures to higher than that of the
surrounding Sea by doing so they are
able to hunt in colder conditions
it's an incredible ability
and it's all possible thanks to a unique
element of white shark biology
watch dogs have two types of muscle
tissue red and white and they use that
red muscle tissue to actually create
body heat
a shark's red muscles located toward the
center of the body are used for
sustained swimming
while it's white muscles are responsible
for shorter bursts of activity
red muscles are responsible for long
duration activity
and help ensure that the animal's core
stays warm even in cold ocean
temperatures
this allows them to believe in the
cooler Waters such as what is
experienced in Western Australia
but one pressing question remains
people in Western Australia have been
taken to the water in winter and spring
for decades
so why the sudden uptick in attacks
starting in 2010.
shark expert Dr Blake Chapman says the
answer may come down to a key factor a
population surge not of sharks but of
people
so the numbers of humans in Western
Australia have been increasing
and the shift hasn't been slow between
June of 2009 and the next year when the
spike began the number of inhabitants
here swelled by forty thousand by June
of 2018
this figure Rose by another four hundred
thousand the fastest growth rate of all
Australian States
numbers are key because Chapman says
that most of the people moving in are
also utilizing one of the state's Prime
resources the numbers of humans on the
beaches and using the waterways here
have been increasing this activity level
has one clear and dangerous Consequence
the more people who are in the water the
more likely a chance of negative
interaction with the shark is
that's what we're seeing now
it seems we only have ourselves to blame
so it could be that the combination of
population surge whale stranding and the
Salmon Run
may have created a perfect storm that
has led to an increase in shark attacks
as the spike continues authorities in
Western Australia remain dedicated to
pursuing prevention measures
and beachgoers worldwide can take solace
in the notion that the behavior of the
Ocean's Greatest Predator isn't changing
to include routine attacks on humans if
they're not out there to eat us they're
not out there to kill us they're
absolutely incredible animals
[Music]
foreign